bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on parle du
nouvel iphone du nouvel iphone 10 iphone
os x apple à sortir un iphone
spécialement pour les 10 ans de l'iphone
un très très bon oeil phone se présente
le futur d'apple avec un grand écran 5,8
pouces oled et ça c'est juste magnifique
alors on va rêver dans cette vidéo les
différentes fonctionnalités étaient
différentes choses qu'on peut faire avec
et vous allez voir que franchement il a
tout pour vous séduire
alors voici si notre iphone 10 alors
pour réveiller il suffit de taper une
fois dessus
il arrive c'est un produit qui est très
réactif grâce à la puissance qui va
relativement vite et qui réagit très
très bien un grand écran avec la petite
encoche envoie alors ici effectivement
c'est que tu as plusieurs personnes que
regrettait set en poche et qui trouve
que c'est un point négatif bon pour ma
part ça me dérange pas énormément on a
quand même un écran alors c'est les
iphone 10 sont les seuls à avoir ce
ratio un format un petit peu particulier
un peu bâtard lorsque vous affichez par
exemple une vidéo bien vous allez la
voir en grand écran mais vous allez
rogner sur l'eau et sur le bas sinon
vous allez voir sur un format plus
classique mais qui n'ira pas sur
l'ensemble de l'écran
après c'est pas fondamentalement bien
bien grave alors on peut faire pas mal
de choses avec ce téléphone vous ouvrez
des applications vous partez du bas vers
le haut et vos revenus à 0 lorsque vous
êtes sur une application vous avez la
petite barre en bas tu sais pas si vous
le voulez bien
hop elle permet de naviguer entre les
différentes applications façon très
intuitive et très sympathique ça c'est
vrai que c'est très très très facile et
très agréable alors lorsque vous voulez
arriver directement sur votre multitâche
évocation des applications qui sont
ouvertes vous mettez du bas vous tenez
ici et vous avez sur votre multitâche et
vos différentes applications donc ça
c'est vraiment aussi très rapide
lorsque vous voulez fermer une
application rien de bien compliqué vous
vous mettez 2 / voulait s'appuyer
ça vous met ici les petits sens interdit
hop pour les fermer vous pouvez aussi
les fermes et directement du bas vers le
haut et comme ça c'est rapide c'est
pratique ça j'ai très très bien on peut
les faire à la masse mais voyez c'est
vraiment simple lorsque vous voulez les
timbres voulait s'appuyer ce bouton là
et le bouton vers le haut alors vous
avez accédé ce qui manque
éteindre appel d'urgence médicale et on
annule personnellement je ne veux pas
encore l'éteindre
le centre notification à changer savait
qu'on avait l'habitude de le prendre du
bas vers le haut pour y aller bon du bas
vers le haut maintenant c'est différent
c'est pour fermer les applications
contre notification se trouve ici vous
descendez et hop vous et vous avez votre
toit de votre centre de notifications
alors ce qui est bien c'est qu'avec ios
entendu pas mal de modifications vous
pouvez les personnaliser
et rajouter directement d'autres icônes
d'autres fonctionnalités leur semblait
déjà vu sur une précédente vidéo
mais c'est vrai que c'est très très
pratique vous appuyez vous revenez
ensuite directement sur votre écran
d'accueil
le pourcentage de la batterie aussi a
disparu on le retrouve dans le centre de
notifications pourquoi tout simplement
parce qu'on n'a plus vraiment beaucoup
de place sur cette page la voyez pour le
m lorsque vous scrollé comme ça
directement une page une nouvelle
fonctionnalité qui est très très sympa
qui était rajouter vous n'avez qu'à
mettre votre doigt au niveau de la
caméra et ça vous ramène en eau
directement vous avez maintenant un
nouveau raccourci qui était lancé sur le
bouton sur le côté vous appuyer une fois
et bien forcément vous allez l'éteindre
vous faites un appui lancé syrie mais
lorsque vous faites troisième fille ça
vous fait un raccourci par exemple ici
on va passer en dark mode 1 2 3 dark
mode un deux trois modes normal vous
pouvez le paramétrer sa directement dans
vos réglages pour pouvoir changer et
avoir d'autres options sera pour
permettre de modifier la luminosité etc
et on a pas mal de possibilités là
dessus autre chose qu intéressant
directement depuis le bouton d'accueil
vous avez des raccourcis qui existent
lorsque en utilisant une 3d touch pense
que voulait s'appuyer ici ça vaut active
votre que vous avez ici à l'arrière vous
laisser depuis sept ans et pour celui ci
ça vous ouvrira votre appareil photo
alors normalement ça vous pouvez régler
et en mettre d'autres directement alors
la grande évolution que vous avez ici
par exemple up
bonjour la grande évolution vous avez si
c'est le mode portrait qui changent
alors qu'on trouve déjà sur l'iphone
cette es7 plus maintenant sur lui de
suite plus mais vous avez en plus du
mode portrait vous avez l'éclairage
naturel que vous aviez l'éclairage de
studio l'éclairage de contour
l'éclairage de seine et l'éclairage de
seine mono alors ça pour l'instant c'est
encore un peu du gadget le détourage est
pas génial c'est une veste en version
bêta donc on espère que ça sera modifié
et corrigé très rapidement
normalement ça devrait être le cas mais
bon pour l'instant tout ce qui est mode
portrait en éclairage naturel ça
fonctionne bien donc l'action n'a rien à
reprocher les écrans oled ce vraiment le
top
en ce moment on l'a sur la lgv 30 on
assure les nouveaux samsung vous l'avez
sur ce nouvel iphone et les écrans lcd
là jusqu'à présent donc il ya du
changement chez apple
un écran oled 5,8 pouces super retina hd
alors vous avez certaines possibilités
ça on le verra prêter dans une future
vidéo grâce à sa caméra qui permet
d'avoir une reconnaissance en trois
dimensions vous allez pouvoir et qui
vont avoir aux animaux ji votre fils il
dit mais bien évidemment aussi le mode
portrait que vous y retrouver
directement sur cette caméra là et ce
qui est très bien c'est que lorsque vous
voulez film et vous
idéal pour faire des blogs filmé avec
les caméras cette fille vous aurez une
qualité qui sera quand même supérieur
par rapport aux iphone précédents alors
la grande nouveauté c'est effectivement
le double appareil que vous avez ici au
format vertical le grand angle et le
téléobjectif l'âge et le modèle en
argent qui est très beau avec le bord
chrome est là qui est vraiment
magnifique d'agresser des rats qui est
sympa on n'a pas cette même jolie
finition mais la finition est quand même
plutôt pas mal il faut le reconnaître
apple a vraiment réussi son coup sûr cet
appareil là alors la seule chose qu'on
peut regretter un petit peu celle des
traces de doigts même si elle a
effectivement maintenant c'est quelque
chose qui n'était pas très fragile en
terme de traces de voix pour l'instant
ce soit encore le cas il ya encore des
petites améliorations à faire mais en
tout cas on sait très bien que ce dos en
verre qui permet d'avoir de la recherche
par action donc ça c'est vraiment pas
mal
alors un nouvel iphone avec de la
réalité augmentée la nouvelle puce à 11
bionique
parce que vous avez le temps de calcul
qui quand même vraiment accéléré de
nouvelles performances par rapport à la
puce a dit ce que vous aviez dans les
iphone cet essai de plus vous le
retrouve également à les mêmes
performances dans le but évident plus
donc ils absolument rien à envier aux
luttes et vie de plus si ce n'est la
grande dalle si ce n'est à l'écran oled
est d'avoir un format effectivement
qu'un peu plus petit par rapport aux 8
plus et un écran plus grand par rapport
aux 8,1 téléphone aussi qu'ils aient une
meilleure autonomie
il a plus de 11 heures pour l'instant
d'autonomie en tout cas ce que ce
téléphone fait vraiment le job il est
très sympa il est pratique et il saura
satisfaire pas mal de monde dès lors que
vous acceptez m 1159 euros pour 64 giga
ou alors 1329 euros pour autant 256 go
mon fils a de bonnes performances c'est
un super appareil mais il n'est pas
forcément à la portée de toutes les
bourses
voilà un petit peu ce qu'on peut dire
pour l'instant sur cet iphone 10 on en
parlera plus longuement directement
notamment de la caméra ici qu'on va
pouvoir tester on va faire une vidéo où
on va parler justement de vidéos sur les
indices des performances de la caméra
arrière mais également de la caméra
avant et vous allez voir que
fondamentalement ça reste un super
appareil un super appareil qui a des
points positifs mais également des
points négatifs tout ça on détaillera on
regardera les photos les vidéos nous
tous on leur parle ensemble
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo mais
témoin qui commence à detroit ce que
vous en pensez est ce que vous vous
pourriez acheter cet iphone dise si oui
est ce que vous attendez que les prix
baissent un petit peu vous rendez les
iphone de l'année prochaine vous mettez
tout son commentaire vous et sa jolie
pousse cette vidéo vous
plus tard moi je vous dis à très bientôt
d'ici là portez vous bien ciao